nicht für die schule sondern für das
leben lernen wir haben wir einander
einstigen poesiealbum geschrieben und
dabei unterschlagen dass es im original
von seneca ursprünglich gerade umgekehrt
ist nicht fürs leben sondern für die
schule lernen hier finden sie das klingt
ernüchternd muss nicht sein behauptet
der professor für
erziehungswissenschaften roland
reichenbach der heute bei mir zu gast
ist
guten morgen herr reich macht für die
schule lernen wir heißt auch eines ihrer
bücher wirklich für die schule lernen
wir unser untertiteln blätter hierfür
ein für eine gewöhnliche institution und
sie haben es erwähnt seien akademiker
wird falsch zitiert sozusagen
allerdings bedauerte dass wir für die
schule lernen und nicht für das leben
mich hat das interessiert diese
dichotomie zwischen schule und leben und
ich glaube das ist sehr problematisch
dass wir sozusagen das leben so hoch
werden gegenüber der schule und
eigentlich dann fragen ob die schule
nicht zum leben gehört ob es eine
vorstufe des lebens ist ob das wahre
leben erst nach der schule wurde neben
der schule stattfindet klingt ja ein
bisschen wie die trennung zwischen der
work-life-balance wo man ja auch immer
das gefühl hat ich so gehört eigentlich
die arbeit nicht zum leben
ja ich würde auch sagen die die schule
gehört zum leben natürlich ist es eine
gewöhnliche jetzt gewöhnliche
institution natürlich ist es auch eine
problematische institution für viele
kennt nicht nur für die kinder und mann
wie jede institution kann es als etwas
aktuelles künstliches erlebt werden also
eine ärgerliche tatsache mit der wir uns
einfach
abfinden müssen dennoch glaube ich dass
die schule heute unter stark zum teil
sehr populäre kritik ist und das hat sie
meines erachtens nicht verdient und es
ist auch gut wenn wir für die schule
lernen dann lernt man wenigstens etwas
ein anderer begriff der auch so ein
bisschen diese trennung aufmacht
zwischen leben und schule ist der
ausdruck der bildungsferne und von ihnen
sagt man ja zuweilen dass sie aus einem
bildungsfernen milieus stammen das
ärgert sich aber immer auch ein bisschen
ja ich würde sagen der begriff der
bildungsfernen machen sie aus den
bildungsfernen milieu würde ich
tatsächlich meinen das ist ein in diesem
begriff höre ich eine verachtung und mit
der kann ich mich gar nicht anfreunden
und es zeigt diese typische verarmung
des bildungs denkens die mit der wir uns
heute abfinden müssen oder nicht
abfinden wollen
wenn wir nämlich bildung und
schulbildung gleichsetzen und das
erstaunt nicht dass bildungsforscher
ganze bevölkerungsgruppen als
bildungsfern bezeichnen können und man
fragt sich wie bildungsnahe die
eigentlich sich selber vorkommen
und ich frage mich auch was die genau
denken was bildung für sie eigentlich
darstellt oder nicht sind tatsächlich
die anzahl bücher die zu hause auf dem
regal stehen
es ist die anzahl der jahre die man in
diesen institutionen verbringt ist das
ein guter indikator um bildungs nähe und
bildungsfernen zu bezeichnen oder zu zu
kennzeichnen ich glaube das ist höchst
problematisch
viele studien behaupten ja aber
eigentlich schon dass das kind sehr viel
zu hause auch lernt nicht zuletzt auch
zb dadurch dass die eltern viel mit dem
kind sprechen sie selber sagen von sich
sie hätten sehr sehr viel ferngesehen so
ist und erst mit zwölf jahren freiwillig
das erste buch gelesen
wie wurden sie denn bildungshungrige ich
glaube wir sind jetzt im fernsehen ich
sage es nicht deswegen im fernsehen kann
man sehr viel blödsinn anschauen aber
auch sehr viele interessante sendungen
und als kind mit meinen beiden grünen
haben wir in der tat sehr viele fans
sehen
gesehen und ich glaube wir haben auch
sehr viel davon profitiert natürlich
hätten wir zum teil andere dinge machen
können statt fernsehen schauen
aber sie ist ambivalent und heute weiß
man eigentlich ist nicht das fernsehen
das irgendwie das problematische an die
bildung ist sondern die zeit die man
verliert und die man vielleicht für
andere dinge einsetzen könnte also ich
würde sagen meine fernseher biografie
sozusagen oder erfahrung hat sehr viel
geholfen mich für bildungsfragen
überhaupt zu interessieren sie haben ja
dann das lehrerseminar gemacht obwohl
sie auch von sich sagen in ihrer jugend
oder kindheit im berner oberland sein
die nicht immer ein einfacher schüler
gewesen und die schule war jetzt nicht
gerade irgendwie der ort der großen
begeisterung
das stimmt allerdings das heißt ich
hatte ich würde sagen dass ich hatte ups
und downs das widerspiegelt sozusagen
die bergwelt höhen und tiefen
und es ist auch wahr dass sich das
lehrerseminar damals das konnte man
damals von sekundarschule in das
lehrerseminar gehen dass sich das
gewählt habe eigentlich nur in
anführungszeichen nur weil ich quasi
nicht wusste was ich machen will
aber ich wusste dass ich interessiert
bin an sport musik und kunst und das
wurde im lehrerseminar doch sehr
gewichtet und das war für mich der
ausschlägen ausschlaggebende grund nach
er eine große karriere zum professor hin
mit verschiedenen stationen auch in
kanada in kalifornien in münster waren
sie lange zeit professor noch einmal
meine frage wie kam es dann dazu von
dieser kindheit im berner oberland wenig
bücher nicht so gern in die schule
gegangen heute hochschullehrer professor
irgendwann muss es ihnen den ärmeln
reingenommen haben mit diesen büchern
und dieser ganzen bildung ja ja ich
glaube relativ früh und wenn ich jetzt
sage oder wenn sie sagen eben
bildungsfernen milieu
dann würde ich das ja verneinen
meine mutter war sehr interessiert dass
wir zum beispiel in die ferien gehen
dass wir nach rom gehen was wir nach
athen gehen dass wir machen die
akropolis anschauen und das würde man
nicht erwarten das ist nicht
selbstverständlich und meine eltern
haben vor allem auch unterstützt dass
ich als erster in den familien ein
instrument lernen durfte aber dann
wollte ich natürlich gleich zwei und
dann habe ich eben zwei gleichzeitige
lernen können nämlich gitarre und
klavier und ich glaube diese
musikunterricht ist für mich sehr
bedeutsam im nachhinein gewesen und ich
glaube diese exklusivität dass man mit
einer erwachsenen person alleine ist 40
minuten lang und das jede woche dass man
über die woche üben muss dass man neue
symbol system geben das notensystem
harmonielehre dass man solche dinge
lernt und dann im nachhinein muss ich
sagen die beiden typen der eine war ein
alter strenger klavierlehrer und jüngere
kita waren eher ausgeflippte sage ich
jetzt mal spät 68er mir eigentlich sehr
viele andere dinge lehrte statt gitarre
aber das sind eigentlich für mich beides
fenster in eine welt gewesen sie im
nachhinein glaube ich sehr bedeutsam
wenn ich ihn jetzt zuhörer verstehe ich
gar nicht gekonnt zu diesem attribut
bildungsferne familien akropolis sehen
gitarre spielen eben ich sage ja die
bildungsferne
dieses wort ist kein mensch ist im
grunde genommen bildungsferne
das ist ja eine eine einem raum
metaphorik nähe distanz quasi und ferne
zur bildung und man fragt sich was
bedeutet das und heute kann man sagen
ich war jetzt in kleinbasel dann kann
man sagen
dort sind sehr viele bildungsferne
menschen das heißt ja quasi
bildungsferne wenn die zu hause arbeiten
müssen und für die kleinen geschwister
schauen müssen statt dass sie für die
schule lernen oder wenn sie im betrieb
arbeiten im laden statt in die schule zu
gehen dann sind sie bildungsfernen das
heißt menschen die verantwortung
übernehmen müssen sind bildungsfernen
andere aber die vielleicht mit 25 30
immer noch an der universität sind und
nicht so genau wissen was jetzt mit
ihrem leben anfangen wollen
die sind bildungsnahe
und da merkt man da kann etwas nicht in
ordnung sein und das verständnis von
bildung es hier sehr reduziert und ich
glaube dass so sollten wir nicht
sprechen aus der pädagogik sowieso nicht
aber leider hat sich diesen begriff der
bildungsferne durchgesetzt er ist aber
auch ein unwort soll 2013 in der
armutskonferenz in deutschland definiert
worden und ich glaube es sehr wichtig
dass aus dem grundwort zu bezeichnen
haben sie gesagt viele kinder lernen
nicht mehr verantwortung zu übernehmen
es gibt ja auch diese tendenz dazu dass
man den kindern vor allem bei bringt
sich um ihre eigene bildung zu kümmern
also sie sollen büffeln und gute noten
schreiben haben sie den eindruck dass
wir die kinder stärker zu kleinen
egomanen erziehen heute das glaube ich
nicht ich glaube eher die frage die mich
interessiert bei diesem ganzen fokus auf
das kind das individuum das hirn dass
selbst das selbst regulierte lärm ist er
was sagt das über unsere welt aus
und ich glaube das müssen wir eigentlich
uns fragen wenn wir jetzt diesen fokus
haben jetzt müssen die kinder alle quasi
wie selber wissen selber können und man
wäre es ihnen nicht zeigen sondern man
will ihnen zeigen wie sie selber machen
können und was sie dann damit machen das
waren ihre sache sein
diese philosophie dieser hintergrund
idee die finde ich befrage nhs wert und
im grunde genommen beunruhigend sie sie
sagt etwas über unserer gesellschaft aus
und nicht über das kind auch nicht über
die güte der lehren sollen sie sagt
etwas aus wo wir uns befinden
und ich glaube das ist unruhigen
beunruhigend weil hier bestimmte aspekte
ausgeblendet werden nämlich unsere
fundamentale abhängigkeit von anderen
menschen
aber wir hören da haben wir selbst
kompetenzen sozialkompetenzen natürlich
fachkompetenz und wir glauben wir
könnten diese klar bestimmen modellieren
usw und klar voneinander differenzieren
aber man merkt so ist es eben nicht
sondern menschen haben ein leben sie
teilen das mit anderen sie haben
probleme sie haben aufgaben die sie gar
nicht gewählt haben und an diesen
aufgaben müssten sie sozusagen
sich abarbeiten und dabei entwickeln sie
kompetenzen und das können sie nur
bedingt in einer institutionalisierten
erziehung oder pädagogik bewirken sie
keine persönliche betroffenheit nicht
herstellen
und man merkt sozusagen diese praxis
dieser herstellungs- modus denn
eigentlich die idee der die idee der
praxis abgelöst hat der stört mich in
diesem ganzen denken dass er weit
verbreitet ist sie sprechen natürlich
damit ein stück weit auch den lehrplan
21 an und der begriff der kompetenzen
sehr hoch gehängt sind es sind 363
kompetenzen die im lehrplan gefordert
werden die einen kinder so erlernen soll
dagegen gab es sehr viel widerstand der
begriff der kompetenz dass ich das
problem
ich glaube mit dem begriff und der
kompetenz ich glaube das ist eine
problematische begriff wir müssen nur
wissen was wir darunter verstehen und es
gibt eine lange tradition
auch der kompetenz erforschung in
sozialwissenschaften nicht nur in der
pädagogik das gibt es in den kognitiven
psychologie
wir finden das in der ethnologie wir
werden diesen 30 40 jahren und da ist
der kompetenz begriff eigentlich ein
anti christliche idee gewesen dass man
quasi die menschen nicht von außen
gesteuert sehen wollte sondern eben die
eigenaktivität den menschen als auch den
kleinen menschen als konstrukteur der
eigenen welt wollte man sozusagen in den
vordergrund rücken und das sind
vorarbeiten die es machen dass wir heute
so einen sehr positiven positive
konnotation von kompetenz haben
und wenn man gegen ein konzept überhaupt
nichts haben kann gegen ein wort gegen
eine hülse und alle nur im kopf nicken
dann entspricht das eine form von
gottesdienst würde ich sagen
und da ist etwas nicht in ordnung das
heißt etwas worüber wir aber wir nur
zustimmen können
das verdeckt etwas das man muss danach
der rhetorik fragen warum taucht das
jetzt auf warum ist es jetzt offenbar
nötig dass wir sämtliche bildungsinhalte
kompetenz theoretisch fassen wollen als
kompetenzen verstehen wollen und das ist
die interessante fragen und und sobald
man dann beginnt näher zu definieren was
kompetenz ist nicht ist dann beginnt der
streit und das ist auch richtig so
ich meine max bank hat man schon
formuliert ist ein mann seine
lieblingszitate es gibt dinge über die
wir uns einigen können komma und
wichtige dinge und ich glaube bleiben
kompetenz ist tatsächlich eine wichtige
frage und die gesellschaftlich cent rang
begriffe sind immer strittig nicht
schwammig jeder kann irgendetwas sagen
sonst sind strittig man kann kein
konsistent darüber reden aber man muss
es tun und was im lehrplan 21 vielen
anderen noblen und großen projekten
einem präsentiert wird ist sehr wenig
strittig
es ist alles klar es bedient sie
eigentlich ein bisschen fürs streiten
dann geht es auch um wichtige dinge aber
umgekehrt sagen sie es herrscht eine
bildungs eine neo money im
bildungssystem wir wollen bauern neue
reformen dort hat man das gefühl man ist
ja alles wieder auf den kopf stellen
dagegen wehren sich ja die neo man es
natürlich war ein wort über das man auch
diskutieren könnte was es ist und es
wird ja niemand eigentlich eine
erneuerung oder der wunsch nach dauer
und erneuerung nach darunter der
neuerung ohne dass man weiß worin das
neue jetzt eigentlich genau besteht
niemand würde in der moderne bestreiten
dass es transformationen und die
neuerungen gibt es gibt selten so etwas
wie radikale revolution das sind aber
unsichere zeiten aber die haben unsere
welt unserer kultur auch natürlich
bestimmt zum glück sind sie nicht so
häufig zum glück sind sie aber
tatsächlich auch passiert dann gibt es
das neue als nicht als revolution
sondern als steigerung etwa im
technologischen bereich
das begrüßen wir in der regel da können
wir irgendeinen technologie eine technik
aus differenzieren und sie führt zu
besseren oder effizienter mit resultaten
und dann gibt es so etwas und das ist
eher ein einer ästhetisierung im
negativen sinn von ästhetik das neue
haus prinzip es muss einfach immer das
neue
das heißt das alte muss behaupten muss
muss begründet werden
das neue nicht aber ein stück weit ist
ihre these doch gegenläufig zum
empfinden der meisten leute viele sagen
ja gerade das umgekehrt und sagen guckt
euch mal die schule nahm das ist
eigentlich ein konstrukt aus dem
neunzehnten jahrhundert eigentlich habe
ich nicht wirklich etwas verändert
gerade deswegen muss es eben neu werden
da würde ich sagen erstens sieht unsere
schule überhaupt nicht so aus wie im
neunzehnten jahrhundert das ist ich
glaube dass das ist eine behauptung die
einfach dahin gestellt wird und zweitens
würde ich sagen das was ähnlich aussieht
von strukturmerkmale hat offenbar eine
bestimmte stärke und sie ist es wichtig
dass institutionen eine auch eine
bestimmte beständigkeit haben aber die
verhältnisse zwischen den schülern
zwischen lehrpersonen und schülern und
schüler haben sich sehr verändert die
didaktischen haben sie verein das hat
sich sehr vieles verändert vieles bleibt
sich eben auch gleich es kann sich nicht
alles verändern
das ist eigentlich elementar was ich
hier sage aber deshalb geht es hier
eigentlich eher um die rhetorik und um
vokabeln statt um tatsächliche
veränderungen die man feststellen kann
dass heißt es sind diskurs konstrukte
und beunruhigend sind die deswegen weil
diese ganze neo money diese ausdruck von
innovationsbereitschaft alle wissen sie
müssen innovieren alle wissen sie müssen
dauernd etwas verändern aber sie wissen
nicht mehr wozu diese innovation
rhetorik hat den fortschritt gedanken
ersetzt fortschritt heißt man weiß woher
man kommt und vor allem wohin man gehen
will
innovation bedeutet man muss sich dann
für ein denn man weiß aber das ziel
nicht mehr richtig und das ist sozusagen
für eine pädagogische hintergrund
philosophie oder überhaupt als
ermöglichung von
von pädagogische praxis keine gute
voraussetzung aber stimmt das wirklich
dass man nicht weiß wohin man geht
christoph einer und der präsident der
eidgenössischen
erziehungsdirektorenkonferenz der sagt
zum beispiel wir sehen es hat zu wenig
ingenieure
wir brauchen da einfach mehr also müssen
die ein stück weit naturwissenschaften
stärke ein bisschen mathematik stärken
man sieht auch wikipedia wissen ist da
für alle zugänglich der computer ist
etwas was unsere welt radikal verändert
hat natürlich muss sich die schule
ändern
ja ich meine natürlich gibt es so
teilsegmente fragen was klar ist dann
diese dieses was sie miteinander
sprechen ist sozusagen die kluft
zwischen beschäftigungssystem und
bildungssystem darf nicht zu groß werden
das heißt es und das ist klar das ist
insofern weiß man diese aufgabe ist sehr
wichtig ob man sie dann aber
kontrollieren kann ob das wirklich
bewirken kann
das ist eine andere andere frage wenn
sie das beispiel des lehrers und leder
ihnen mangels nehmen während rundet
jagen etwa 25 jahre gab es zu viel 25 zu
wenig etwa 50 hat es bestimmt und das zu
steuern ist sehr sehr schwierig aber
natürlich ist ja gar nicht so sehr daran
dass man kein ziel hat sondern es liegt
eher daran dass man nicht in der lage
ist dieses ziel dann adäquat zu
versorgen
nein ich glaube es gibt es gibt sehr
viele bienen ziele man quasi weiß wir
haben zu wenig von dem wir müssen mehr
investieren das heißt noch lange nicht
dass man weiß wie man es macht das ist
einfach einen eine diagnose eine
defizitäre und man schaut wie könnten
wir wir könnten wir hier diesem defizit
begegnen und momentan wissen allem und
naturwissenschaften technik informatik
das ist ein expandierenden markt
beziehungsweise leute fehlen wie man
sich nicht alle aus dem ausland drohen
da müssen wir was machen
ich glaube das ist unproblematisch diese
diagnose und da wird auch sehr viel
da wird auch sehr viel investiert aber
wenn wir dann fragen die pädagogischen
fragen im engeren sinne
da gibt es meines erachtens eine größere
verunsicherung und symptomatisch dafür
sind sind ist meines erachtens diese
diese ganze kompetenz welt und ich würde
schon sagen mit mit der hannah arendt
dass hier etwas passiert
als ob die ältere generation der
jüngeren generation nicht die
verantwortung wirklich abschieben will
aber sie möchte einfach die kinder und
jugendliche so ausstatten dass die dann
selber machen können wie sie müssen
und das meine ich damit tun was man weiß
nicht mehr wohin es wohin die reise
gehen sollen
und wenn sie in irgendwelchen bereich
das muss das kann auch das
gesundheitswesen sein es muss nicht die
bildungsbereich seien die menschen sind
immer aktive dauern müssen sie neue
programme irgendwelche reformen
administrative art politischer art pakt
ans praktische rad und sie wissen nicht
genau warum es erfordert mehr zeit sie
glauben vor allem nicht das ist ein
fortschritt ist dass es entscheiden es
ist nur eine innovation sozusagen
aber es geht nicht vorwärts und mir
gefällt die metapher von virilio rasen
des stillstands menschen sind diese in
diesem in diese aktivität aber wechselt
ja wie im hamsterrad aber merken nicht
dass es vorwärts geht und ich glaube das
muss man ernst nehmen dieses unbehagen
sonst sagt man einfach in die lehre
verstehen es nicht die ärzte verstehen
es nicht die ganzen berufsgruppen sie
verstehen es nicht und ich glaube das
muss man ernst nehmen das heißt die die
pädagogische tätigkeit wir die tätigkeit
muss einen sinn macht
diese muss geteilt werden kann sind es
sehen sie es geteilt ist das ist keine
privatsache und ich glaube hier gibt es
doch an bestimmte herausforderungen
problem
sie sprechen von dieser neo money sie
kritisieren dass es viel innovation gibt
ohne wirkliche fortschritt idee würden
sie denn sagen eigentlich kann er uns
zurücklehnen unsere schulen sind prima
das würde ich nicht sagen ich würde
sagen schulen sind erstens nie prima sie
sind ebene problematisch überhaupt das
gesellschaftliche leben
ist problematisch und die schule das
bildungssystem ist ein subsystem des
gesamtgesellschaftlichen systems neben
gesundheitssystem transportsystemen und
zwei franken systeme und die
widersprüche der gesamt des
gesamtsystems werden spiele spielten
sich auf der subsystem ebene und das
heißt wir haben es hier eigentlich mit
einer komplexen institutionen zu tun und
deshalb ist es nicht sinnvoll sie so
unterkomplex zu kritisieren
ob man sich verteidigt oder negativ
sozusagen kritisiert ist dann immer noch
die frage aber ich erfahre die meiste
schuld kritik als dogmatische
besserwisserei im grunde genommen wenn
man er schaut und kritik heißt sich zu
fragen wie gut sind eigentlich die
gründe die wir haben für bestimmte
behauptungen oder die andere für
bestimmte behauptungen vorlegen zb dass
eine reform nötig ist wie gut sind die
belege die empirischen belege die
methodisch gut sie woher woher wissen
wir dass sich die quelle galt
automatischen besserwisserei ist das ist
einfach die tatsache dass alle mitreden
wollen dass die schulleitung ein
problemfeld ist bei dem alles ich auch
experten fühlen
ich glaube nachdenken ist es nicht sehr
produktiv und nachdenken ich nicht das
muss ich jetzt mal kurz nicht sagen
das dogmatische ist mangel an nachdenken
überhaupt ein mangel an denkt
dogmatische besserwisserei ist sehr
häufig und das muss das kann auch sein
dass das was behauptet wird durchaus
walid ist wenn sie jemand aus der
wirtschafts fragen was soll die schule
dann hat er klare vorstellungen und das
ist in ordnung wenn sie jemanden fragen
der sich eher mit der zivilgesellschaft
und den staatsbürger thum beschäftigt
der wirt gute antworten haben wenn sie
jemanden fragen aus dem psychologisch
pädagogischen bereich der wird
vielleicht sagen
die sinnsuche oder das wissen die freude
an der kultur
das sind die relevanten dingen und dann
wird man merken das ist alles richtig
das scheint doch alles plausibel zu sein
man merkt dann h das sind ganz
unterschiedliche perspektiven die man
auch schule haben kann wenn sie aber
jetzt irgendjemand nehmen das beste weiß
wie sie sitzen ihr habt zum teil auch
hier an diesem tisch dann kann dann
wissen die dann wissen sie genau was zu
tun ist was die fehler sind der schule
was man besser vergessen muss dann und
ich frage mich nur woher wissen sie das
das heißt dass eppig demo logisch dass
selbst befragen
woher weiß ich das eigentlich ist sehr
gering und das ist doch mal nicht nein
ich natürlich wenn sie mich jetzt fragen
würden und wie soll die schule aussehen
das fragen sie vielleicht vielleicht
auch nicht dann hätte ich schon ein paar
ideen
das ist klar aber ich wollte damit sagen
viele haben ein paar ideen
das heißt noch nicht sehr viel aber wenn
wir einen diskurs führen
dann sollten wir den auch so führen dass
wir fragen woher wir etwas wissen wie
gut wir etwas begründen und das ist ein
das ist etwas was ich vermisst natürlich
nicht ich allein sondern sehr viele und
das ist ein unbehagen an einer kultur
wenn nicht einmal begründet wird sondern
nur noch behauptet wird dass etwas
wirklich nötig ist das glaube ich ist
eigentlich mit der wissenschaft sowieso
nicht vereinbar
den wissenschaftlichen ethos aber auch
mit einem demokratischen nicht und dafür
will sich die menschen ein bisschen wie
begangen jetzt heißt es dass man das
machen und es wird einfach behauptet das
heißt erfahrung wird sozusagen entwertet
ohne aufzuzeigen wie es bisher war was
genau die probleme waren und warum jetzt
eine andere praxis wirklich nötig ist
und warum wir gute gründe haben zu
behaupten dass eine bessere praxis und
das ist schon erstaunlich dass mit
meiner institution sich so tief in ihm
folgt sozusagen verankert ist so glaube
ich das ist keine gute art und weise wie
politik betrieben wird und ich glaube
das ist sehr verbreitet und das ist das
unbehagen lehrpersonen werden sagen
bürokratie und weiter ich sehe das nicht
bürokratie ich glaube es eher eine
metapher für diese gängelung die man
fühlt sieht ihren zuweilen auch luhmann
niklas luhmann den großen
systemtheoretiker und weisen darauf hin
dass ja eigentlich ein problem der
moderne genau das ist das eigentlich
alle mitreden wollen
man möchte die sachen kontrollieren aber
man hat früher schon darauf hingewiesen
in der moderne brauchen wir frauen
vertrauen weil kontrolle funktioniert
gar nicht mehr weil die im stück weit
gar nicht mehr das wissen haben die
sachen zu kontrollieren
das heißt vertrauen wäre das stichwort
der stunde aber gibt es nichts glaube
ich oder wenige gegenstände bei denen
wir so wenig das vertrauen haben dass
die sache wirklich noch funktioniert
woher kommt denn dieses misstrauen in
das bildungssystem also oder glauben wie
man redet dass die ganze zeit schlecht
steht nicht mal die hacken und ich
glaube es funktioniert so vieles so sehr
gut dass dir dass diese diagnose nicht
stimmen kann
ich würde gleichzeitig sagen die schule
ist unfair
sie wird wahrscheinlich auch unfair
bleiben wenn man dann hier modellierten
sie verändert wird da kann man einfach
neu bestimmen wer sozusagen die
verlierer und die gewinne sind oder wo
man etwas verändern will das ist in
ordnung aber insgesamt gibt es sehr
viele aufgaben und funktionen die die
schule erfüllt und die sollte man nicht
einfach ignorieren
und dazu gehört etwa ist nicht nur
dieser ganze idee der zivilität des
gemeinsinns es gehört auch dazu
die sorte von objektivität die wir in
der schule haben das heißt ihm dadurch
dass wir eine sache ausgerichtet sind
und die lern gegenstände sich meistens
irgendwie an wissenschaft anlehnen oder
zu ihr nicht in widerspruch sein sollen
und die art und weise wie wir im
kollektiv drüber diskutieren und nicht
jede für sich nicht jede eingeschlossen
in seiner psychologie das halte ich für
sehr bedeutsam das heißt argumente
können zehn es gibt besseres oder
schlechteres wissen es gibt offene
fragen es gibt den streit es gibt die
auseinandersetzung das sind alles ganz
zentrale also das kind diese diese
erfahrung machen kann dass es sozusagen
um argumente geht nicht einfach um und
macht spuren nicht nur macht und dann
natürlich macht man über die erfahrung
dass die argumente dann nicht
ausschlaggebend sind aber legitim ist
das nicht das heißt die macht ist ein
faktum aber die macht gehört zum leben
die frage ist nicht wollen wir macht
oder wollen diese nicht sondern welche
gebrauch von macht ist legitim und
welches nicht legitim
eine quelle von unbehagen oder
unzufriedenheit ist natürlich immer auch
das tv ranking also diese
vergleichsstudien der oecd die schweiz
jetzt auch nicht immer gerade
unglaublich gut abschneidet sie sind ein
pisa kritiker warum
ja also wenn man sagt kritiker heißt man
ist dagegen
ich bin an sich nicht gegen solche
leistungsvergleich im gegenteil ich mag
die eigentlich wenn man so diese
olympiaden diese es interessant zu sehen
dass zum beispiel wenn jetzt an
deutschland denken dann sieht man
abnehmen ist etwas so gut ist zwischen
brasilien und mexiko wenig interessant
oder bayern ist natürlich besser aus
bremen bayern ist etwa so gut wie
österreich oder schweden aber dann gibt
es noch die finnen sie werden jetzt auch
schlechter wie wir neu gelesen haben die
koreaner bleiben immer noch oben und
dann dass wir dich einfach interessant
nur was machen wir damit und ist das ein
wissen das die schulpraxis besser macht
natürlich nicht ist ein wissen was hilft
die steuerung der bildungssysteme besser
zu kontrollieren nein sicher nicht
aber genau diese behauptungen sind mit
diesen vergleichen einhergegangen
die die kita ist von der oecd
die pisa und zu suchen sozusagen
initiiert worden das hat überhaupt keine
pädagogischen gründen und später nach
folge gab es interessante untersuchung
deshalb würde ich nicht sagen das ist
alles quatsch
aber wenn dann these eines solches
gewicht bekommt das konnte man in
deutschland auch hier zum teil nur dass
man einen sehr teuren katastrophen
diskurs initiiert wie schlimm es ist in
deutschland aber wir sind zu holen ja
das geht gar nicht
wo stehen wir international die
franzosen ganz anders gesagt ist nicht
so schlimm ist ja nur international die
haben ganz andere logik gehabt und jetzt
haben wir diese ranglisten aber jeder
mensch weiß dass diese ranglisten die
schule nicht verbessern werden sondern
die praxis kann man nur in der praxis
verbessern und man kann sich auch
untersuchen wie die verbesserung
funktioniert aber nicht mehr
das ziel der pisa-studie war natürlich
auch ein internationaler vergleich
insofern als man weiß bildung ist heute
auch ein globaler wettbewerbsvorteil
und genau um dieses thema geht es auch
im film alphabet von erwin wagenhofer
und der kultur blatt heraus ausschnitte
gezeigt wir schauen uns einnahmen das
maß im globalen bildungs rennen ist
heute das pisa ranking und da liegt
china auf platz eins ausbildung ist hier
alles chinas schüler lernen am längsten
haben den größten prüfungsdruck wohnen
schlafen am wenigsten die nebenwirkung
selbstmord ist die häufigste
todesursache bei chinas jugendliche
das lässt ihn kalt den internationalen
koordinator der pisa studie andreas
schleicher der film alphabet begleitet
ihn auf inspektionen beim großen vorbild
bin ich in ländern wie china
doch irgendwo optimistisch wir sehen wo
die reise hin läuft und eben auch bereit
sind die zukunft anders gegen die
gegenwart abzuwägen als wäre das tun
ein stück weit hätte gesagt bildung
schafft zukunft eigentlich doch eine
gute sache
ja sicher
die frage ist jetzt was peter bedeutet
und was diese idee dieses sogenannte
bildungs fieber jetzt der chinesen oder
überhaupt die ostasiaten bedeutet und
ich glaube dass das internet hat
beeindruckend das heißt es kommt in
ostasien zum zum ausdruck dass man
wirklich an die zukunft glaubt dass man
da investiert und glaubt es rentiert
sich das aber sehr wichtige nebenfolgen
hat die man nicht gutheißen kann ist
auch klar aber nochmals ich werde ich
möchte das schon noch sagen
zu behaupten dass pisa des standard sei
und dass man mit pisa mit dem pc
soldaten wesentliches über die
leistungsfähigkeit der systeme aussagen
kann das würde ich doch bestreiten
und ich kenne auch kollegen die sie
würden sie sehr sie mit peter vertraut
sind die wissen das haargenau sie sagen
natürlich öffentlich nicht unbedingt
weil es nicht funktional
man kann nur pisa weiterführen wenn man
behauptet das sei auch ein relevantes
wissen
in deutschland wurden jetzt bisher in 15
jahren 100 millionen euro für die pisa
andere leistungsstand erhebungen
ausgegeben chronik millionen euro man
kann sagen es ist in der tat nicht viel
das bildungssystem ist kostet viel mehr
jeden monat kostet milliarden
und deshalb kann es also nicht so
wahnsinnig schlimm aber ich würde die
relevanz der daten nicht die ihm das ist
nicht interessant ist aber die relevanz
für steuerung und für die bewertung der
leistungsfähigkeit der schulsysteme das
würde ich doch ein bisschen bestreiten
das heißt ein bisschen die sonne sehr
stark bestreiten und auch sagen hier
dass es nicht eine beschreibung von
realität sondern das sind vor das
eigentlich normative npd-mann gibt vor
was die wissen und dann schaut man wo
stehen sie jetzt
man schaut nicht was unter welchen
bedingungen drei erreichen erreichen sie
was das heißt man schaut nicht nach
leistung
man muss wissen was die bedingung sind
und was sie innerhalb von bestimmten
zeit dann kann man liebe leistung sagen
aber so sicher aber wenn wir nochmal zum
beitrag zurück gehen da immer wieder
beeindruckt leben china zu sehen viele
asiatische länder rungen eindruck
kapitalbildung sethos oder einen lernort
osten vielleicht auch zeit
unterschiedliche dinge
sie sind ja auch begeistert vom
konfuzianismus und sagen da ist
eigentlich eine bildungsidee
vorherrschend die eben gerade anders
funktionieren wird und ich krieg das so
schlecht zusammen mit dem was wir hören
von asien tiger mom phänomene die kinder
werden richtig gedrillt und sie kommen
jetzt mit dem konfuzianismus verfasst
das miteinander zu ja das ist natürlich
schon
es wirkt schon wie ein widerspruch das
erste ist begeistert bin ich nicht nur
sehr interessiert und zwar nicht weil
ich diese wirklichkeit die hier gezeigt
wird jetzt mit konfuzianismus
gleichsetzen und auch gutheißen würde
das würde ich ab streiten sondern ich
mein interesse bezieht sich eher auf die
schriften nicht auf diese praxis
tatsache ist dass die das lern autos
natürlich ein wichtiger teil des
konfuzianismus ist und das neo
konfuzianismus und was mich daran
interessiert ist genau nicht dieses
pieces genauen ziele da sind sollen dass
man in diesen schriften eine ganz andere
auffassung von lernen und bilden an sich
bilden findet
nämlich dass man sich auf etwas
einlassen muss sich mit etwas
beschäftigen muss und gleichzeitig nicht
weiß wohin das führt und die ziele
ergeben sich durch das lernen selber und
sie haben wir eigentlich bei konfuzius
ähnlich wie schon bei sokrates diese
idee dass selbst sorge um das ist
wirklich eine ganz andere idee
und deshalb ist wenn jena ist nicht
gleich konfuzius dass das konfuzianische
geprägte gesellschaften sind das ist
klar aber da muss man differenzieren
zwischen der philosophie der idee und
eine praxis dass mir bei diesem plädoyer
für die selbst sorge vielleicht ein
stück weit beim kompetenz begriff und
der kritik an lehrplan 21 wo die idee
eigentlich ein stück weit ist oder so
läuft die kritik und die berechtigten
das können wir diskutieren das alles was
wir wissen sollen eben ein können sein
muss es muss immer was nützen und
dagegen wehren die dich ja auch mit
blumenberg
bildung ist kein arsenal sondern ein
horizont was genau ist der kritikpunkt
ja also ich würde mal so sagen wenn alle
bildungsinhalte als kompetenzen
definiert werden sollen das ist sowieso
ein problem
wir müssen jetzt länger diskutieren und
wenn dann alles einen transfer nutzen
haben sondern es muss alles für etwas
gut sein das ist an sich auch nicht
problematisch ist problematisch wenn man
behauptet man wüsste
wozu es gut ist aber das weiß man eben
nicht das heißt ich bin sicher nicht
gegen gegen utilitarismus auch nicht in
seiner vulgären formen oder gegen
instrumentalist muss oder
funktionalismus das merkt man wenn man
wenn man keine funktion für andere hat
wenn man von anderen nicht mehr in
instrument sein kann dann hat man ein
echtes problem
das heißt funktionieren können ist sehr
wichtig sich gegenseitig instrument sein
können ist sehr wichtig nutzen ist sehr
wichtig aber was nicht geht ist dass wir
glauben wir könnten vom wissen einen
direkten link eine verbindung zum nutzen
machen das wissen wir nicht und die
selbst zur selbstsorge gedanke ist ein
ganz anderes
der pädagogische selbstsorge gedanken
schon in der griechischen antike ist
eben dass wir zwar für uns selber sorgen
müssen dass die selbst und die welt
sorge in wirklichkeit das gleiche ist
das haben wir ein kompliziertes mussten
wir später bei humboldt aber dass es
keine privatangelegenheit ist sondern
dass wir eigentlich den anderen brauchen
wir sind fundamental abhängig von ihm
und ich was mich interessiert jetzt an
diesen ganzen kompetenz beschreibungen
ist nicht dass sie irgendwie bösartig
sind das sowieso nicht ändern oder
sollen sie sind von einem optimismus und
von einem geist geprägt denn ich nicht
nachvollziehen kann man kann nicht
selber bestimmen wo zu etwas gut ist
sondern wir erfahren dass und die
kompetenzen wie sie wissen erfahren wir
durch erfahrung und die erfahrung können
sie nicht herstellen
sie können persönliche bedeutsamkeit
durch die schule nicht herstellen
das ist unfreiwillig sozusagen großteil
der entwicklung ist unfreiwillig ein
stück weit haben sie jetzt kritisiert
dass wir so tun als könnten wir den
transfer nutzen immer bestimmen also wir
können sozusagen oder wir haben die
schwierigkeit dass nicht alles wissen
den direkten nutzen hat aber nutzen ist
sehr wichtig gleichzeitig sagen sie aber
auch momentan es gibt auch wissen das
nützt vielleicht nie etwas
sie sprechen von einem sinn überschuss
den man in der schule auch herstellen
können sollte sie plädieren dafür sich
kunst anzusehen musik zu hören sie
lieben gedichte zitieren berlin land die
parzen das wunderbare gedicht also da
habe ich aber schon den eindruck es geht
ihnen nicht darum dass sie sagen wenn
wir könnten wäre es gute kann alles
wissen nützlich genau sondern es geht um
andere dinge auch es geht es natürlich
jedes um andere dinge ich wollte vorher
nur sagen nutzen ist nichts schlechtes
sondern es ist klar dass die dinge auch
etwas nützen können müssen aber es muss
nicht alles etwas nutzen und dann ist
die frage was ist denn nutzen erweitert
hat nutzen so definiert eine nützliche
idee ist eine idee die uns auf weitere
ideen bringt das heißt wir haben
vielleicht eine sprache für jetzt
was das heißt nicht dass wir genau
wissen was wir damit anfangen
aber es ist eine bereicherung unseres
semantischen netzwerkes eine bereichung
die perspektive die wir auf etwas haben
und das kann uns sozusagen nutzen in
einen anderen situation aber wir können
nicht wissen und selber nicht bestimmen
was sie uns nutzen wird und die schlimme
frage ist sozusagen vor dem lernen
wissen zu wollen was es bringt was
bringt es dicke bücher zu lesen wenn es
auch dünne gibt was bringt es überhaupt
dünne bücher zu lesen wenn es auch
zusammenfassung gibt warum sollten wir
überhaupt noch lesen auserlesen können
wenn sie das internet gibt ja und zanken
und dann haben sollten gelesen haben die
genau das sage ich ihnen gleich
man könnte ja sagen unser verständnis er
wenden wir brauchen einfach diese
kompetenzen zum beispiel den
methodenkompetenz wenn ich dann was
wissen muss sie haben gesagt wie
gebildet dann greife ich zu dann kann
ich und dann habe ich das wissen bildung
ist was ganz anders aus dass bildung
heißt wir beschäftigen uns mit etwas und
dadurch werden wir andere personen
dadurch werden wir differenzierte ohne
es bestimmen zu können
man kann den menschen nicht von außen
bestimmen in die bildung
man kann den menschen nicht bilden er
kann sich nur selber bilden
aber im grunde genommen kann er sich
auch selber nicht auf souveräne weise
bilden man weiß nicht wie man verändert
wird durch eine bestimmte lektüre durch
eine begegnung mit einem menschen mit
einer kultur mit einem problem was ich
habe mit meinem freund der mich verlässt
mit meiner mutter die stirbt solche
erfahrungen die nicht gesucht worden
sind prägen unser leben sehr und deshalb
haben hat die erfahrung etwas mit diesem
widerfahren ist mit diesem erleiden oder
passiv erdulden müssen
und wir brauchen dann meistens die
andern um diese erfahrung aktiv
sozusagen zu formen und artikulieren und
dann werden wir tatsächlich reicht und
wenn sie den menschen zuhören wenn sie
sagen ich habe eine erfahrung gemacht in
meinem leben habe ich oder denn diese
schule habe ich ihre fragen war dann
meinen sie nicht ich habe ein tolles
lebens gehabt sondern sie meinen ich
meinte es geht so aber ich habe gemerkt
das geht nicht so ich musste um lärm
zu sagen ihr plädoyer für dicke bücher
für sinn überschuss erinnern mich auch
ein bisschen an ein interview das ich
kürzlich gelesen habe im schweizer monat
der neusten ausgabe vom juni 2015
da hat der schriftsteller thomas juli
man ein langes interview gegeben und er
kritisiert den gleichheitssatz in den
bildungsinstitutionen und plädierten
stück weit auch wieder für
bildungsideale die vielleicht auch hier
und da elitär sein können also wieder
die großen bibliotheken anpeilen
haben sie auch ein stück war tief in
sich drin sowas wie ein traum davon
klosterschulen filat ein nein nein
überhaupt nicht
und ich würde mich auch wenn also ich
weiß nicht ob das jemand gleichheits mir
gesagt hat ich habe überhaupt nichts
gegen elfenbeintürmen und ja das gibt's
ja lang er ist schon lange nicht mehr
entlohnt
aber was mich stört an einer solchen
idee ist die gleichheits lief das ist
gar kein gutes wollen und ich will nur
sagen wenn schon demokratie und wenn
schon bildung da hat die gleichheit im
ganz wichtigen stellenwert und
gleichheit ist eben meistens nicht
institutionell herstellbaren gleichheit
ist eine praxis sie können ernst
genommen werden
als mensch sie können als kind ernst
genommen werden wenn die lehrperson oder
die mutter fragt warum hast du das getan
ja sag mal warum dann heißt es ich nehme
deine gründe seine motive für deinen tun
ernst das ist unterstellung sozusagen
von gleichheit von vernünftigkeit und
diese pädagogische praxis ist
fundamental und das ist eigentlich die
praxis die dann vielleicht bewirkt
vielleicht auch nicht dass man sich für
bestimmte dinge interessiert oder nicht
deshalb von gleichheits lief das ist ein
das ist ein ganz schön gesund absolut
erteilt es gibt so viele langweilige
dicke bücher dass ich jetzt kein
plädoyer für dicke bücher sondern ich
würde nur sagen einfach dicke bücher
nicht dass das das nicht geht das würde
ich sagen nein wir nutzen schauen sie
wenn sie sich kennen sie interessieren
für dinosaurier und irgendetwas oder
dann sagt man ja auch nicht interessiert
sich doch
diese dinosaurier konnte was nützliches
interessiert nicht ausgestorben oder was
nicht ausgestorben ist das macht man ja
nicht und das ist eigentlich das heißt
eine bestimmte leidenschaft man gibt
sich auf etwas hin
zuerst vielleicht nur die dinosaurier
weil die so oder so monströs sind dann
später sind es die techniken vielleicht
wie weiß man was die von der farbe
hatten eigentlich und dann plötzlich
merkt man da kommt sehr vieles zum
vorschein was wichtig ist zum beispiel
eben etwas theologische frage sie haben
vorhin mir angekündigt wenn ich sie dann
auch frage dann geben sie mir ein paar
ideen wie sie die schule verändern
würden aber sagen sie mir sagen sie
nicht geplant und habe ich jetzt dieses
dieses wenig konkret wissen was denn
ihre ideale schule wäre oder wo sie
denken da hätten wir wirklich
veränderung
ich glaube ich glaube dass die ich
glaube dass die schule auf sehr
unterschiedliche weise sehr gut sein
kann
ich glaube dass auch die lehrpersonen
sehr auf sehr unterschiedliche weise
sehr wirkungsvolle und wichtige wichtige
entwicklungen stimulieren und
voranbringen kann meinen beiden erkennen
und dass man das nicht definieren kann
das ist das heißt dass es ein streit
geprügelt nein ein dass ein streit gibt
über oberflächen phänomen ob man das so
oder so keine didaktische frage frontal
oder mit gruppenunterricht oder so das
glaube ich ist ein das ist das sind
oberflächen finden handy interessiere
mich immer weniger
ich glaube gute schule hängt von
bestimmten elementaren habe und wir
wissen natürlich ist die lehrperson
zentralen die lehrperson repräsentiert
die institution und die institution
repräsentiert die kultur des wissens und
des könnens was an das kind
weitergegeben wird und daher sind die
vier kriterien die ich quasi so einfach
pädagogisch formulieren würden was eine
gute schule ist oder was eben gute
lehrpersonen sind weil es gibt keine
gute schule ohne gute lehrperson und
beantragt heute eben noch gute werte
sonntag nicht kompetent man sagt immer
was ist ein guter weg dann kann man sich
warum
was die vier kriterien sind dass erstens
die lehrpersonen das was sie tut
für wichtig finden muss sie muss diese
wichtigkeit zeigen
entweder es bestimmte leidenschaft sagen
das ist wichtig das was wir hier tun ist
nicht einfach nur weil es im lehrplan
steht oder weil ihr das müsste sondern
es hat eine bedeutung für uns für unsere
fähigkeit glaubwürdigkeit sozusagen das
des wissens was weitergegeben werden
das zweite ist dass nicht erst dass es
das erste ist was er zeigen was das
zweitweise zeigen muss oder sie zeigen
muss ist dass ich will dass du das
lernst das muss man aber zeigen diese
erwartung muss sichtbar gemacht werden
und ist nicht ob du wenn du magst und du
kannst selbst nein ich möchte dass du
das lernst um das dritte ist die
unterstellung du kannst das lernen wenn
du dir mühe gibst und das ist das tönt
einfach dass es sehr schwer
gegenüber kindern und jugendlichen von
dem man nicht denkt dass sie eine
großartige bildungskarriere genau
gegenüber denen dieses zu zeigen dieses
konto faktisch ist von größter bedeutung
und das ist das ist professionalität das
ist schwierig das nicht die aktive
methode sondern dass eine haltung die
gezeigt werden muss und das vierte ist
die vierte des kinos gezeigt werden muss
ist also das ist wichtig du kannst das
lernen du sollst dich lernst du kannst
es lernen und ich helfe dir dabei das
muss glaubwürdig sein und ich würde
sagen das ist mir gesagt das wussten wir
schon immer ja aber dann kann es
vergessen
man kann es vergessen wenn wir meinen
wenn wir vom leadership zum management
abdriften und dann wenn wir glauben es
dann braucht die richtigen methoden dann
verflüchtigt sich sozusagen die
personale aspekt die leppe somit ebene
wenige wichtig dabei ist sie besonders
wichtig für das kind und sein lernen sie
erweisen da ja auch auf die studie von
john hartigan neuseeländischen
bildungsforscher der während 15 jahren
250 millionen schülerinnen und schüler
beobachtet hat und eigentlich ja gezeigt
hat wie wichtig die lehrperson ist bei
mir kommt man einfach der eindruck auf
dann hat ein kind ja einfach enorm viel
glück oder entsprechend pech je nachdem
welcher person ist landet das ja auch
ein stück weit wieder gegen die
gleichheit also zum zum zweiten
zunächst zum ersten das erste ist also
jetzt schon hat er hat ja in
anführungszeichen nur methan studien
meter analysiert und es ging nur um den
lernerfolg und dann hat diese faktoren
gefunden
237 und die dann gebündelt und die
lehrpersonen zeigte sich als die
wichtigste faktoren gruppe für den
lernerfolg so was nicht schule vor geist
und das ist natürlich ein wichtiges
datum
und er ist die frage was kann man damit
machen und da wird jetzt es gab diesen
hat die hype und das ist ja auch
interessant weil es sozusagen ein
bisschen gegen gegen diese pädagogischen
ideen und sie auch hier im lande
herumschwirren steht weil wenn man dann
schaut und wie sind die lehrpersonen sie
besonders erfolgreich sind beim lernen
dann sind sie eben die bei hätte die
neue lenkung vor lenkung viel feedback
viel kontrolle genau nicht to sell wird
eigenständig selbst reguliert und 20
genau nicht also viel autorität macher
sagen einfach lenkung und lenkung heißt
ich würde so sagen und ich dass das weiß
man ja aus das weiß man auch studien
auch studien kleines studien die in der
schweiz durchgeführt worden sind
die die hohe lenkung ist nicht gegen das
kennt und wenn sie ein leistungsstarkes
kind sind schulisch leistungsstark dann
sind sie eigentlich in jeder welt in
jeder didaktik können sie überleben und
werden gute leistungen zeigen aber die
leistungsschwachen und die mittel
starken die können schwächer werden wenn
sie ihnen zu viel zumuten deshalb oder
zu viel eigenständigkeit zumuten
und deshalb würde ich das sehr
ambivalent anschauen sagt individuell
machen jetzt alle für sich das kann die
schere er noch öffnen
das heißt die neue lenkung ist nicht
gegen das kind gerichtet und das weiß
eigentlich jeder auch mal praktisch
gewesen einem pädagoge weiß wer mühe hat
dem muss man viel kontrolle geben kind
kontrolle ist nichts was böse sondern
man hilft dem kind zu sagen schau jetzt
hast du das gemacht das kannst du auch
nicht jetzt macht man das nächsten
diesen schädigt das heißt klein maschine
vorn gehen und wenn man diese idee also
die hohe lenkung für solche fälle als
schlechte pädagogik anschaut dann
merkt man dann haben wir ein feld wurde
das vokabular nur noch politisierte und
das haben wir weitgehend heute aber es
ist ja tatsächlich so sie denn auch
immer wieder russo es gibt diese idee
bei jean jacques rousseau und die hat
dann auch die reformpädagogik stark
inspiriert montessori und so weiter
diese idee dass eigentlich alles im kind
schon angelegt ist und hauptsache man
dass das kind in der natur seine
erfahrungen machen das kind wird sich
schon selber entwickeln also gerade
nicht dieses starke lenkungs manöver der
song auf der lehrerin
ja ja das ist also das ist nicht meine
musik sozusagen mein ressourcen sich
daraus ja es ist auch nicht der uso weil
das der e mail ist eigentlich ein
gedankenexperiment und man kann den so
naturalistisch lesen aber dann versteht
man sowieso meines erachtens nicht so
ist eine ganz widersprüchliche figur der
sich seine widersprüche sozusagen
bewusst ist und er ist eigentlich ein
seismograph der gesellschaft gewesen in
der er gelebt hat und es sicher eine
höchst problematische figur auch als
person gewesen und deshalb diese
pädagogische und reformpädagogischer
verklärung von rousseau die ist ganz
schwierig hingegen ihn als interessanten
philosophen zu lesen ist glaube ich sehr
wichtig und die es gibt hier nicht ein
zurück zur natur sondern es gibt in
seiner pädagogik natürlich zum ersten
mal wirklich ausgereift
die idee dass man quasi die entwicklung
des kindes kennen muss sozusagen seine
natur kennen muss um dann eine
angemessene pädagogik zu haben insofern
könnte man sagen wo es so ist eine der
ersten der eine entwicklungsorientierte
pädagogik versucht und das ist die natur
ist nicht der wald sondern die natur ist
die entwicklung des kindes
und natürlich ist er voller widersprüche
etwa eben diese e-mail
niemand von uns möchte doch emil sein
dann ist er mit einem schlag zusammen
und weil es immer allein es ist ganz
fürchterlich und eben muss man alles
allein selber herausfinden
dann ist man im wald und dann muss weil
hat man angst als e-mail und dann sagt
der typ wie man sich dann in diesem
modus orientieren müssen dass das kann
ja nicht sein das sind ideen die nicht
sozusagen in die praxis umgesetzt werden
dennoch habe ich immer den eindruck es
gibt ja schon so eine sehnsucht danach
in alternativen schulen darüber
nachzudenken wie viel schule braucht es
denn eigentlich viel steuerung denken
wir an die villa monte im kanton schwyz
ein schulprojekt bei dem die kinder eben
keine lehrpläne haben sondern sich
komplett frei eigentlich bewegen und man
sieht am ende der schulkarriere die
haben noch was gelernt die haben sogar
das meist ebenso gut gelernt wie die
anderen kinder also wozu braucht es
schulen wenn eigentlich auch wie remo
largo sagt die neugier was lernen wollen
in jedem kind schon angelegt ist ja das
ist eben jetzt das würde jetzt sagen das
ist das ist ein nobles das in nobler
lewis muss das ist eine eine verklärung
sozusagen das der natur dass es die
natur das bild die natur des kindes und
seine entwicklung seine neugier und 200
niemand würde das bestreiten dass das
das modell sein kann wie man das
schulsystem in einer modernen
gesellschaft organisiert dass das geht
nicht und natürlich man kann das machen
als romantisch das ist jetzt eine schul
kritik die man ein romantischer schul
kritik ist wenn man sage ich nicht dass
es falsch ist sie trifft etwas wie viele
andere kritiken auch aber sie negiert
das system
sie bedeutet unterschiedlich und zwar
widersprüchlichen funktionen der schule
für die gesellschaft etwa die selektions
funktion
das können sie mit dem so nicht richtig
erklären und auch mit der neugierde des
kindes und selektion heißt schaffung von
ungleichen zukunftschancen
am schluss soll nicht alle die gleichen
berechtigung haben das heißt wir haben
herrn wettbewerb auch innerhalb der
bildung und da können sie lange mit dem
hirn bei spitze oder mit mit kind und
seine neugierde beilage oder dann kommt
der trend der brecht ja und wir haben
alle ganz starke ideen warum die schule
schlecht ist und wie man sie verändern
sollte
gemeinsam ist ihnen ein und komplexes
verständnis von bildung system die die
komplexität der aufgaben und funktionen
und sobald man diese einsichten ein
bisschen ernster nimmt kann man nicht
einfach aus diese partikulären
perspektive die als sicher berechtigt
ist ja eine medizinische perspektive ist
eine andere als eine ökonomische und ist
eine andere als eine juristische und das
sind alles perspektiven die unser
verständnis von schule prägen und
pflegen müssen und die institution der
schule ist nur bedingt eine pädagogische
institution nur bedingt es sie hat sogar
aufgaben die pädagogisch schwierig sind
wie zb wie zb die selektion wenn ich
ihnen so zuhöre kriege ich wie so ein
bisschen den eindruck es gibt einen
widerspruch es gibt einerseits ihr
plädoyer dafür schule aus system zu
bewahren zu sagen das ist teil der
gesellschaft da hat die schule eben auch
vielleicht widersprüchliche funktionen
die selektion
sie hat auch sie sagen an einer stelle
sehr schön eine aufbewahrung funktion
irgendwo müssen die kinder ja sein
gleichzeitig sagen sie aber auch immer
wieder wir müssen schule schauen auch
kritisch ansehen oder die neo money
kritisch ansehen damit nicht alles was
wir lernen etwas nützen muss sondern es
diesen zehn überschuss noch gibt also
ich verstehe jetzt noch nicht ganz sie
müssen sich schüler gesellschaft die die
schule ist ein teil der gesellschaft
sie ist konstitutiv für moderne
gesellschaft und die reform schulen die
sie jetzt genannt haben viele versuche
die sind sehr wichtig und die reform
schulen haben das pädagogische denken
und die in die schulische praxis in den
staatlichen schulen sehr verändert über
die zeit man das nicht nur vom auf der
vokabular ebenen was ich sagen wollte
ist wenn die dinge kompliziert sind
soll man diese komplexität angemessen
berücksichtigen und ich wollte sagen
dass manche nur deshalb so überzeugen
können
sie haben jetzt einige figuren genannt
weil sie die komplexität ignorieren sei
es bewusst oder nicht
weil sie leidenschaftlich eine sicht
haben dann heißt es kindgerechte schule
als ob klar wer was kindgerecht sei
eigentlich bedeutet
ob das das kennt als zukünftige
arbeitnehmer oder auch das kind jetzt
und dann merkt man doch um so wenigstens
wie viele reformpädagogen haben gemerkt
die bedürfnisse der gegenwart das kind
ist die muss man ernst nehmen das ist
sozusagen das ist das ist ich würde
sagen das ist der große blick auf die
kinder
aber es gibt bedürfnisse der zukunft es
gibt die bedürfnisse der
gesamtgesellschaft und jetzt zu glauben
dass das so ein harmonisches ganzes
geben würde
das ist ein schlechter platonisch muss
aber offenbar und dann kann man nur
aufrechterhalten wenn man nicht die
system ebene mit berücksichtigt sie sind
selber vater von vier kindern ich glaube
das hilft jetzt 14 das älteste 23 25 25
alle sind in die normale regelschule
gegangen
das heißt sie hatten selber nie auf
vater den eindruck sie müssen die kinder
war in eine reformschule schicken
doch doch ich hätte sie ihn oft
gewünscht ich habe überhaupt nichts
gegen die reform schon im gegenteil ich
habe ich habe etwas gegen bestimmte
ideologisierung aber ich glaube schon
dass in sehr vielen reformschulen eben
genau wirklich gute praxis geleistet
wird gute arbeit geleistet wird und das
hängt meines erachtens ganz entscheidend
von der identifizierung diese der
lehrpersonen die dort sind zusammen und
natürlich dem rückhalt aus dem
ideologischen rückhalte eltern die ihr
kind dann dorthin schicken und
vielleicht auch unter umständen das kind
selber dass diese exklusivität dann
vielleicht ein bisschen schätzen lernt
das hab ich würde sagen das finde ich
exklusiven der schweiz etwa 1 5 prozent
glaube ich sind in der privaten schule
untergebrachte sind sehr wenige und ich
habe dagegen habe ich überhaupt nichts
trotzdem bin ich natürlich nicht nur von
meiner herkunft her sondern auch um eine
politischen einstellung ganz auf der
seite
der der staatlichen schulen und der
staatsaufgaben was die bildung
anbelangte wenn ich ihnen zuhöre kriege
ich den eindruck vielleicht stimmt im
schulsystem der satz progressiv zu sein
heißt manchmal auch konservativ zu sein
erreichen doch ich danke ihnen für
dieses gespräch
wir lernen bekanntlich nicht nur mit dem
kopf sondern auch mit hand und herz ums
lernen oder sinnliche erfahrung geht es
heute abend kurz nach elf in der
sternstunde kunst im kino wie tanzträume
der film zeigt jugendliche bei der
probenarbeit sein stück von pina bausch
am kommenden sonntag spreche ich
anlässlich des 80 geburtstags des dalai
lama mit seinem übersetzer und
vertrauten mit dem buddhistischen mönch
matt erika schön wenn sie wieder dabei
sind jetzt aber erst mal einen schönen
sonntag
[Musik]